* Mysteriöse, verspielte Musik *
Es ist natürlich ein steiniger Weg.
Etwa wie diese
bucklige Kirchgasse da.
So in etwa ist der Weg,
den wir beschreiten müssen.
Es ist kein einfacher Weg.
Man braucht auch viel Kraft,
aber wenn wir alle zusammenhalten,
schaffen wir es vielleicht.
Das ist extrem wichtig.
Wie immer in den Bergen.
Beat Jost,
Gemeindepräsident von Albinen.
Jost sagt, sein kleines Dorf
stehe kurz vor dem Tod.
Nun wollen es die Bewohner
um jeden Preis retten.
(Mann) Langsam!
Wegzug aus dem Tal.
Geht es?
- Ja.
Ist so gut?
Roger Haudenschild und Elma
Anthamatten ziehen nach Albinen.
Das ist ja ein Traum!
Umziehen ist schön.
Ich mache das zum letzten Mal
in meinem Leben.
Roger Haudenschild hat zusammen
mit seiner Freundin ein Haus gekauft.
Jetzt werde ich sesshaft.
Ich habe eine tolle Frau
kennengelernt
und von der Gemeinde
ein gutes Angebot erhalten.
Ich habe auch schon länger
hier gewohnt, elf Jahre lang.
Dann bin ich mal kurz weggezogen,
weil ich unten
ein Haus bauen wollte.
Doch das wäre viel zu teuer gewesen.
Wollen wir hier unten ...
- Ach was, da runterbinden, fertig.
Verdammter Mist!
Roger Haudenschild
und Elma Anthamatten
haben von der Gemeinde Albinen
für ihr Haus je 25'000 Fr. erhalten.
Dafür müssen die beiden
mind. zehn Jahre im Dorf bleiben
und 200'000 Fr. investieren.
Die  gebürtige Philippinin
lebt seit acht Jahren im Wallis.
Ich hatte noch nie
von diesem Ort gehört.
Für mich war es:
"Oh, mein Gott!"
Wegen ihm bin ich nach Albinen
gezogen, wegen meines Freundes.
Die beiden kennen sich
seit einem Jahr.
Nicht wahr, Mahal?
- Oh yeah, baby!
Die Zukunft in Albinen kann beginnen.
Der Touristenort Albinen
im Oberwallis. 250 Leute wohnen hier.
In den letzten Jahren
wurden es immer weniger.
Einst gab es hier eine Post, zwei
Banken, eine Schule und junge Leute.
Jetzt ist das Dorf am Aussterben.
Mehr als die Hälfte der Einwohner
ist über 60 Jahre alt.
Geld hätte die Gemeinde genug,
doch es fehlt der Nachwuchs.
Gemeindepräsident Beat Jost
will das ändern.
So. Mal sehen, was wir da haben.
Hilfe von aussen erwartet
der linke Politiker nicht mehr.
Heute ist das Berggebiet
kein Faktor mehr in der Schweiz.
Selbst im Bundesrat
ist seit dem Abgang von Adolf Ogi
niemand mehr da,
der weiss, wo das Berggebiet ist.
Das ist ein Drama.
Auch im Kanton
haben wir die Situation,
dass man von morgens bis abends
darüber nachdenkt,
wie man die kleinen Gemeinden
beseitigen könnte.
Jost sagt, die Gemeinde könne sich
nur selber vor dem Untergang retten.
Die Zeit der Dorfkönige und der
politischen Grabenkämpfe sei vorbei.
Nun müssten sich alle gemeinsam
fürs Überleben engagieren
und Ideen einbringen.
Ein solcher Vorschlag aus dem Volk
brachte das Dorf im November 2017
beinahe zum Kollaps:
Junge Bewohner hatten die Idee,
finanzielle Anreize zu schaffen,
damit Junge und Familien in Albinen
bleiben oder gar hierherziehen.
Geld für Einwohner -
darüber wurde abgestimmt.
Der Vorschlag löste ein weltweites
Medienecho aus und einen Rummel,
den man hier an einer Urversammlung
noch nie erlebt hatte.
Der Gemeindepräsident
fürchtete um die Unabhängigkeit
der zukunftsweisenden Abstimmung.
Meine Botschaft ist:
Respektiert hier
diese Urversammlung!
Hier findet Demokratie statt
und nicht ein Medienspektakel.
Trotz Kritik und Spektakel
sagten die Albiner deutlich Ja
zu der Vorlage.
Doch das Dorf kam nicht zur Ruhe.
Im allgemeinen Getöse ging unter,
dass das Geld der Gemeinde
an enge Bedingungen geknüpft ist:
Für die sog. Wohnbau-
und Familienförderung
kommen längst nicht alle infrage:
Wer über 45 ist, kriegt kein Geld,
und Ausländer brauchen
eine Niederlassungsbewilligung C.
Trotzdem trafen 12'000 Anfragen
aus aller Welt ein.
Das sind Bewerbungen, als würde man
sich um einen Job bewerben.
Mit Referenzen,
Zeugnissen, Fotos, CDs ...
Sehen Sie, das ist ein Bild
einer Familie, die sagt:
"This is our family."
Eine riesige Familie.
Das war 2004.
Und ein Baby fehle da noch.
Wir hatten unglaubliche Sachen:
Uns haben Professoren
aus Südamerika geschrieben,
die in Südamerika
Bienenforschung betreiben.
Die haben uns geschrieben,
Albinen wäre ein idealer Ort, um
die Alpenbienenforschung zu machen.
Man könne hier ein Institut machen,
und sie würden garantieren,
dass immer zehn bis zwölf
Professoren da seien.
Sie sagten, man könne in Erschmatt
eine Aussenstelle machen
und eine in Inden, um zu beobachten,
wie diese Bienen fliegen.
Ja, das ist interessant.
Noch heute kämen Leute von weit her
ins Dorf, in der Hoffnung,
bleiben zu können.
Jost sagt, es komme vielleicht
dereinst der Tag,
wo man auch dieses Fenster
öffnen müsse, um nicht auszusterben.
Elma Anthamatten
und Roger Haudenschild
sind seit Kurzem
Besitzer dieses Hauses.
Darin steckt ihr Erspartes
und der Zustupf der Gemeinde.
Das ist das neue Daheim.
Es herrscht noch ein wenig Chaos,
weil wir
noch nicht eingerichtet sind.
Aber das eine oder andere
sieht man wohl.
Oh, was ist da?
Zwei Wohnungen im Haus vermieten sie,
das mittlere Stockwerk
haben sie bezogen.
Das ist das Schlafzimmer.
Ja, aber das ist nur ...
Wir haben etwas aufgestellt,
aber es ist so ...
Ja ...
Unsere Matratze kommt
in ein oder zwei Wochen.
Danach sieht es nicht mehr aus,
als hätte eine Bombe eingeschlagen.
Die beiden unterstützen die Wohnbau-
und Familienförderung der Gemeinde.
Auch andere sollen davon
profitieren können, sagen sie.
Ich finde das nicht seltsam, nein.
Ich finde es eher
die Liebe zum Detail,
weil man an diesem Dorf hängt
und alles probiert,
damit das Dorf nicht untergeht.
Uns geht es hier gut, wir haben
unsere Ruhe. Was will man mehr?
Nichts!
Das Glück der beiden
ist auch das Glück von Albinen:
Die Gemeinde hat mit ihnen
zwei Einwohner mehr.
Es ist Mitte Herbst.
Albinen hat
zum ersten Dorfmarkt aufgerufen.
An 27 Ständen
verkaufen Einheimische ihre Ware.
Ihr zwei, ein Gläschen Wein?
Oh, fall mir nicht jetzt schon um!
Ein Gläschen neuer Wein,
ein Gläschen warmer Wein,
Rotwein, Weisswein?
Spendet doch etwas
für den Kirchenchor!
Alles, was schon verkauft ist,
umtischen!
Ich habe bald nichts mehr.
Jetzt habe ich noch etwas
gebrannte Creme.
Gemeindepräsident Jost ist zufrieden:
Der Markt ist ein voller Erfolg.
Die Idee dazu
entstand in einer Albiner Spurgruppe
und kommt
von der 30-jährigen Muriel Steffen.
Die Gemeinde ist super engagiert,
wenn etwas läuft, wenn etwas geht.
Die Leute machen selber mit.
Das ist super
und eine gute Voraussetzung.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist die neue
Wohnbau- und Familienförderung
schon fast ein Jahr in Kraft.
Gemeindepräsident Jost, der
Transparenz und Offenheit hochhält,
muss deswegen
nach wie vor Kritik einstecken.
Soll ich ehrlich sein?
Ich finde es nicht gut.
Jeder muss mit dem Herzen
und dem Gefühl hierherziehen.
Er muss mit Freude hierherkommen.
Was sagt der Gemeindepräsident dazu?
- Der ist da nicht gleicher Meinung.
Aber ich finde einfach,
du musst Freude haben an der Natur.
Nein, wir können die Meinungen ...
Das ist gut, das ist okay.
Wir kommen schon wieder.
- Ich hoffe es.
Beat Jost
nimmt es äusserlich gelassen.
Die offizielle Mehrheit im Dorf
unterstützt die Argumentation
der Gemeinde.
Die Gemeinde
hat nur dann einen Aufwand,
wenn sie auch einen Nutzen daraus
zieht. Das ist clever.
Ich finde es sehr gut.
- Was finden Sie?
Ich finde es gut,
man muss etwas probieren.
Das ist eine von diesen Ideen.
Es gibt so viele Ideen.
Andere Gemeinden
machen andere Sachen.
Warte, Jonathan,
du willst ein gelbes.
Andere Familien entzweit diese Frage.
Hier kannst du altes Holz kaufen.
- Ja, ja.
Das ist meine Mutter.
Er findet es gut und Sie?
- Ich finde es schlecht.
Sehr schlecht.
- Warum?
Die haben hier
noch keinen Franken Steuern bezahlt.
Wir haben Zeit unseres Lebens
Steuern bezahlt.
Sie sollen uns Alten
auch einmal etwas geben,
z.B. die Steuern erlassen.
Du kannst doch zufrieden sein,
wenn du Steuern bezahlen kannst.
Dann hast du etwas verdient.
Die Mutter
ist nicht gleicher Meinung?
Nein,
die ist nicht gleicher Meinung.
Da werden wir nie
gleicher Meinung sein.
Ist es ein Quatsch?
Es ist nicht Quatsch. Ich habe
gesagt, ich bin nicht dafür, fertig.
Ich habe meine Meinung,
und er hat seine Meinung.
Das ist wunderbar.
Siehst du,
so gehen die Meinungen auseinander.
Schauen Sie, das ist Elma.
- Die kennen wir schon.
Hallo!
- Und die kommt hier nach Albinen.
Die kennt ja fast die ganze Welt
und kommt nach Albinen.
Das kommt doch nicht von ungefähr.
Das kann nicht nur die Liebe sein.
Das muss auch die Natur sein.
Das stimmt.
- Nicht wahr?
Ja.
- Ja.
Was hält Junge in einem Dorf,
das selten so belebt ist
wie an diesem Tag?
Severin Hermann hat auswärts studiert
und ist nach Albinen zurückgekehrt.
Er schätzt die Ruhe hier.
Hermann gehört zu den Mitinitianten
der Wohnbauförderung
und möchte vielleicht selber einmal
davon profitieren.
Mit hiesigen Kräutern,
angebaut auf Terrassen rund ums Dorf,
versucht er sich
ein Standbein aufzubauen.
Die zeitaufwendige Arbeit
gewinnbringend zu betreiben,
sei allerdings schwierig.
Bei all diesen Gesuchen,
die eingehen,
für die Leute,
die hierherziehen möchten,
ist die Schwierigkeit immer,
hier einen Job zu finden.
Das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste.
Wenn es einem hier gefällt und man
einen Job findet, ist es super.
Wenn man keinen Job findet,
wird es schon schwierig.
Viele Albiner finden nur auswärts
Arbeit. Die Jobs sind unten im Tal.
Der Arbeitsweg, v.a. im Winter,
je nachdem beschwerlich.
Fischfabrik Valperca in Raron.
Mit Warmwasser vom Lötschberg
wird hier Eglifisch gezüchtet.
Elma Anthamatten
arbeitet seit sechs Jahren hier.
Ihre Arbeit
beginnt frühmorgens um 6 Uhr.
Weil so früh noch kein Bus fährt,
bringt sie Freund Roger
täglich mit dem Auto zur Arbeit.
So umständlich der Weg und
so frostig die Arbeitstemperatur:
Für einen Job nimmt Elma das in Kauf.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Ich habe so ...
Ich mag es.
Ich mag die Kälte.
Es ist nicht für alle so,
aber für mich ist es kein Problem.
Damit der Arbeitsweg
zum neuen Wohnort Albinen passt,
lernt sie nun Auto fahren.
Zurück in Albinen.
Roger Haudenschild
hat im Dorfladen Ware bestellt.
Die Gemeinde hat den Laden
vor drei Jahren gekauft.
Er drohte zu verschwinden,
weil er nicht rentierte.
Das Defizit von mehreren 10'000 Fr.
jährlich deckt nun die Gemeinde.
Das könne und wolle man sich leisten,
das sei Service public,
sagt der Gemeindepräsident.
Das nehmen wir auf die Rechnung.
- Jawohl.
Nimmst du die Kiste mit?
- Nein, ich nehme eine Tragtasche.
Vielen Dank.
- Danke.
Bis bald, tschüss.
- Schönen Tag.
Für sein Restaurant kauft er
regelmässig im Dorfladen ein.
Das sei praktisch,
wenn auch etwas teurer.
In Albinen gibt es mehrere Beizen.
Die mitten im alten Dorfkern
gehört Rogers Mutter.
Hallo, Mama.
Hallo, Roger.
Geht es gut?
- Ja, bei dir?
Super, sehr gut.
- Super.
Eines nach dem anderen.
Hannelore Tsokhim hat sich mit ihrem
kleinen Restaurant Godswärgjistubu
eine Nische geschaffen.
Auf dem Teller landet,
was im eigenen Garten wächst
oder aus der Region kommt.
Pro Tag gibt es ein Menü.
Dank Mama hat der gelernte Koch
einen Job in Albinen.
Wir wechseln uns ab.
Wir machen hier alle alles.
Der eine putzt das WC,
der andere macht den Service.
Der eine kocht, der andere ist
im Büro, der andere im Garten ...
Was gerade anfällt.
Wir haben keine fixen Posten.
Das macht es so interessant.
Man hat nicht immer
die gleichen Abläufe,
die gleiche monotone Arbeit.
Nach 9 Std. Arbeit in der Küche
kann man sagen:
"Ich habe genug.
Jetzt hole ich etwas im Garten."
Oder man bügelt die Wäsche.
So bringt man Abwechslung rein,
damit es nicht statisch
und monoton wird.
Roger Haudenschilds Mutter
ist ursprünglich
aus einem Nachbardorf von Albinen.
Als Roger klein war,
lebte sie mit ihm im Unterland.
Vor 15 Jahren
zog es sie wieder in die Berge.
Die ersten drei Jahre
waren steinpickelhart.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich es nochmals tun würde.
Aber ich musste immer an diese
Stimme denken, die mir sagte:
"Eröffne eine Beiz!"
Heute weiss ich,
dass es das Richtige war.
Ich bin sehr gerne Wirtin.
Ich mache das gerne.
Die Leute kommen, haben Freude,
und dann habe ich
noch mehr Freude und ...
Ich weiss auch nicht, keine Ahnung.
Einfach Freude.
* Verspielte Musik, Glockenläuten *
Es ist Montagabend im November.
Elma Anthamatten geht zum ersten Mal
in den Albiner Damenturnverein.
Entschuldigung, ich bin zu spät.
Hallo!
Salü!
Brauche ich auch Schuhe?
Wo ist der andere?
Ah, hier.
Der Damenturnverein
ist einer von sechs Vereinen im Dorf.
Aktuell zählt er 22 Mitglieder.
Herzlich willkommen, Elma.
Wir machen nie ein grosses Theater.
Wir freuen uns immer
über Neuzugänge.
Wir machen heute
ein spezielles Aufwärmen.
Und zwar gibt es
verschiedene Posten.
Diese Person, die den Posten leicht
joggend hat, macht zwei Runden,
also wirklich leicht joggend.
Wenn sie zwei Runden gemacht hat,
sagt diese Person:
"Jetzt den Posten wechseln!"
Gut, dann geht es los.
Ah, die Musik!
Jung und Alt
sind in diesem Verein gemischt.
Dieses Turnen ist einfach,
macht aber auch müde.
Ich bin bald müde.
Für Elma Anthamatten wird es vorerst
bei diesem einen Besuch im Turnverein
bleiben.
Zeitlich passe es gerade
nicht so gut, sagt sie.
Feiertag in Albinen.
Die Bestrebungen,
das Dorf zu beleben, tragen Früchte.
Albinen erhält
den Oberwalliser Heimatschutzpreis.
Vielen Dank.
- Gratulation!
Machen wir gleich ein Foto.
Der Gemeindepräsident
möchte nicht den Eindruck erwecken,
das sei alles
auf seinem Mist gewachsen.
"Albinen zeigt mit seinem Projekt
stellvertretend für viele Walliser
Bergdörfer, modellhaft auf,
wie man der Problematik
der aussterbenden Dorfkerne
entgegenwirken kann."
Die Meinung der Jury:
"beispielhaft und preiswert".
Wir gratulieren. Bravo!
Zur Feier des Tages spendiert
die Gemeinde im Burgerkeller
ein grosszügiges Abendessen.
Und der Heimatschutz erklärt,
was mit "beispielhaft" gemeint ist.
Es muss darum gehen, dass die Leute
wieder spüren, wo sie herkommen,
was für Werte sie haben.
Und dass sie Sachen umsetzen können.
Wie es jetzt v.a.
die Gemeinde Albinen macht:
Sie bezieht die Bevölkerung
relativ stark mit ein.
Es wäre interessant,
wenn das andere Oberwalliser
Gemeinden auch so machen würden.
* Lautes Stimmengewirr *
* Glockenläuten *
Es ist Winter geworden.
Roger Haudenschild
und Elma Anthamatten
wohnen seit drei Monaten
in ihrem neuen Haus.
Wir sind angekommen.
Hier ist unser Flur.
Da hat sich noch nichts verändert.
Was neu ist: Wir haben jetzt
eine Matratze im Schlafzimmer.
Die würden wir euch gerne zeigen.
Eine Matratze,
was man zum Schlafen so braucht.
Ja.
Habt ihr euch eingelebt?
Tipptopp, sehr gut. Wunderbar!
Zufrieden. - Ja.
Schön, nicht wahr.
Wir haben Freude.
Zehn Jahre müssen die beiden
in Albinen bleiben.
Sollten sie vorher wegziehen,
geht der Zustupf ans Haus
von insgesamt 50'000 Fr.
zurück an die Gemeinde.
Mein jetziges Gefühl sagt mir,
dass ich bleiben werde.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
was in 20 Jahren ist.
Vielleicht habe ich keinen Job mehr,
vielleicht muss ich woanders hin,
weil ich mit allen Streit habe
und sie mich nicht mehr hier wollen.
Ich kann nicht sagen:
"Ich bleibe auf Biegen und Brechen!"
Solange es mir gefällt ...
Die Zukunft kennt niemand.
* Verspielte Musik
übertönt das Gespräch. *
Für die Gemeinde
war es ein erfolgreiches Jahr.
20 Personen sind zugezogen.
Ein Teil davon
dank des Förderprogramms.
Fürs Jahr 2019 hat Albinen
das Wohnbaubudget aufgestockt.
Drei neue Gesuche sind hängig.
So, jetzt sind wir in der ...
... in der
altehrwürdigen Burgerstube.
Der Gemeindepräsident Beat Jost
wagt zu träumen -
hier im Burgerhaus,
wo einst die Schule drin war.
Ein grosser Traum!
Man vermisst den Lärm,
den Pausenlärm
oder wenn sie auf und ab gehen.
Das vermisst man schon
ein bisschen.
Es ist ein riesiges Handicap,
keine Schule zu haben.
Ist der Traum erreichbar?
Ich sage immer Ja.
"Seien wir realistisch,
versuchen wir das Unmögliche!",
hat, glaube ich, mal jemand gesagt.
Aber es ist ein grosser Traum.
Realistisch sein
und das Unmögliche wagen.
Mit dieser Parole der 68er-Bewegung
will Jost mit seinem Dorf
in die Zukunft aufbrechen.
Gelungen ist in kurzer Zeit
schon vieles, was unmöglich schien.